couldn't think of anywhere better to
have the word grin there there are
dragons flying on the wall of the
terrible emanations incredible raisins
you don't even need to ship in the
hangar absolutely they're all here and
wake up Kings bugzilla Lauren confusion
I've got everything a fantastic venue
you kind of got the right
I mean people love this I know the moves
on speaking as a fan of the show believe
me I have a huge family I don't actually
read the script registry right that's
because I know I'm try to avoid that one
ever calls the boy like to say I live
for as long as well don't want to know
but I think one of the reasons why the
show has been so phenomenally successful
a partially incredible writing apart
from the acting performance in the
production values you literally don't
know what's going to happen next in each
other and it's some of the best
television I've ever seen I mean this
being such a pro you every actor needs a
certain amount of arrogance alias i'm
good i can do this I could do that I
wonderful but whenever you're sitting in
a room on any given day with Charles
dance Diana rigs and Nikolai and Lena
Headey your second finger code i'm going
to say rumor these people
nike you guys are gonna love season 5